[Music]
thinking about Buddhism as a religious
tradition requires us to keep in mind
it's deep roots as well as its wide
branches the roots of Buddhism stretch
back in time to about the 5th century
BCE a time of great social economic and
political change Buddhism's beginnings
were profoundly shaped by these
conditions a change in ancient India but
Buddhism also represents a distinctive
and innovative response to these same
conditions while Buddhism has its
historical roots in India reverence for
the Buddha Buddhist thought and practice
and Buddhist institutions spread first
throughout Asia and then across the
entire world thus to understand Buddhism
as a religion we always have to consider
its deep roots in time as well as its
wide branches in space Buddhists see the
origins of their religious traditions in
the life of a prince named Siddhartha
Gautama Buddha secants of his life
portray him as leaving behind his royal
status his family as well as his palace
to set out to find answers to deep
questions about suffering and its causes
as well as to find out whether freedom
from suffering and death is possible
after years of searching and effort he
discovered what he was seeking and this
discovery is encapsulated in the epithet
Buddha the awakened one the name Buddha
that no parent ever gave indicates that
the Buddha is to us as we are to people
who are asleep the name is a celebration
of his achievement on the basis of what
he discovered the Buddha began to teach
the Dharma truth with a capital T and
the diversity of Buddhist thought over
the ages across Asia represents the
efforts of countless men and women to
understand and realize this truth and
especially to understand and realize
what the Buddha taught us about reality
and human flourishing the Buddha not
only taught ideas but also a way of life
the Buddha established institutions that
grounded the community that developed
around him and teachings that provided
guidance to that community on how to
live so that its members could achieve
enlightenment themselves those who set
out to live as the Buddha taught are
called the Sangha from the beginning the
Buddha's disciples included both female
and male monastics as well as male and
female laypeople this way of life in
these institutions were enduring but
they also proved to be very adaptable to
new settings and circumstances as early
as the first century the tradition began
to travel over the Silk Road into West
and Central Asia and by the eighth
century
Buddhism was well established in China
Korea and Japan
Buddhism also spread south across India
to Sri Lanka and to Southeast Asia from
Burma to Vietnam and Java this spread of
Buddhism across Asia enriched the
Buddhist heritage by the addition of new
texts into the canons of Buddhist
scriptures and in this regard Buddhists
have had more open canons than have
Christians and Muslims in time some
Buddhist communities also developed dual
canons in which one portion of Scripture
was interpreted in the light of the
subsequent Canon of scriptures that was
deemed to be closer to the intentions of
the Buddha as a teacher Buddhist dual
canons are analogous to the combination
of the Old Testament and the New
Testament in the Christian Bible or the
Quran in relation to the texts of other
peoples of the book the Buddhist
heritage was also greatly enriched by
the translation of Buddhist scriptures
into many different languages including
Pali and Sanskrit in South and Southeast
Asia to Tibetan and Chinese in Central
and East Asia the translation of
Buddhist scriptures into different
languages was always an enormous project
since the canonical collections of texts
that carry the Buddha's teachings can
include thousands of individual texts
the complexity and diversity of Buddhist
thought and practice the richness of its
character in local settings are so
pronounced that when Europeans first
encountered Buddhists in their
explorations at the beginning of the
colonial age it took them quite a while
to realize that the religion they
encountered in sri lanka was
historically related to what they saw in
japan and yet amidst all the diversity
and complexity of ideas practices
experiences values and institutions we
can see that buddhists still have much
in common and that they share especially
a sustained attentiveness to suffering
and
they have suffered just as the Buddha
said about his long career of teaching
both formally and now it is only
suffering and the stopping of suffering
that I described
[Music]
you